and of course if we have some super long
flight paths that are combinations of
these that obviously the raytracer the
recursive ray tracer cannot take this
into account why is that that's the big
question let's go back to the
illumination equation and imagine that
I'm hitting the diffuse surface what do
I do I try to emphasize this earlier but
I will emphasize again that I take the
perfect reflection barrage it doesn't
matter if it's diffuse or specular I
take the perfect reflection direction
well if I do this I have no idea about
the surroundings of the object I have no
idea what is for instance above this
diffuse plane if there is some red
object I don't I don't shoot the radar
in order to get some indirect
illumination so I will have no idea
about the surroundings of this object
now if I switch to global illumination
however there is this integration and
the integral part of the integration is
the incoming light the incoming radiance
and how I can integrate this over the
hemisphere is basically sending samples
out in every direction in this
hemisphere now if I do this then I will
know about the surroundings of the
object if there's a red wall or a red
object nearby or the desert nearby then
I will have samples of the incoming
light and therefore it will appear in
the color of the object this is
fundamental this is the very important
way to understand why ray tracers are
missing these effects now let's talk
about the real deal the real
physically-based we already have models
how does it defuse brdf look like it
looks like this so fr is the brdf Omega
Omega prime or incoming and outgoing
directions X is a point on this object
these are probabilities now this is
weird because I'm used to formulate so
if I'll talk
if you shinning I've seen hell dot end
us that's a formula with variables but
this this is a freaking number what do I
do with this number it's one over PI bar
does this even make sense
can someone help me out with this it's
bogus online under it so this one of our
PI means that if this is a scalar if
this probability distribution is a
scalar remember that this is the
distribution of the possible outgoing
directions so imagine this scenario up
here where you have an incoming
direction and if I have a completely
diffuse material it means that it will
diffuse the incoming light in every
direction so all possible outgoing
directions on the hemisphere have the
very same probability and if they have
the very same probability then this
should be a number then the whole brdf
should be a number because whatever
directions I specify here I will get the
same probability and I can scale this
one over pi with Rho which is the albedo
of the material because manual materials
reflect all light in fact most or if not
all of the materials we know absorb some
amount of light so this is again a
number this can be wavelength dependent
because it depends how much you absorb
on the red Channel how much you absorb
on each Channel but this can be
potentially zero and then you have a
black body something that absorbs
everything so you can call it you can
you can change the color of the object
if I'm not using the right terms but I'd
like to really intuitive so the oviedo
is going to give the color of the object
this we can specify non zero okay the
next question is is this a probability
distribution function of course it is
why because it's because it integrates
to 1 there are some other rules that we
are going to disregard with respect to
probability distribution functions how
much does it integrate to this
integrates to 1 why what does the engine
I say well 1 over I integrated from zero
to PI what does it mean I have a
rectangle that is that has the height of
1 over pi and it has the width of I what
is the area of the rectangle let's
multiply these two sides so it's a times
B a is PI B is 1 over pi just multiply
the two and do that one so this is
indeed a probability distribution
function good to go
what about specular be RDS DC these are
what describe mirrors how can I write
such a brdf it's a bit trickier because
it is fundamentally different than just
diffuse materials why they don't diffuse
incoming light in all possible
directions but what is possible is only
one outgoing direction I see only one
thing in the mirror not the mixture of
everything like on the walls
so this means that one outgo interaction
is going to have a probability of 1 and
every single other choices have a zero
probability so this is indeed the
probabilistic model that can be
described by a Delta distribution the
other distribution means that one guy
has a probability of 1 and everyone else
has 0 so it's like elections in the
dictatorship is this a probability
distribution function it is but I put an
asterisk there because I'm going to talk
a bit more about this but let's let's
say for now that it is because this is 1
for 1 incoming direction and 0
everywhere else so we have the one that
we're looking for and there are also
glossy DRDs we haven't been really
talking about this in the first lecture
of mine there was some V area which was
called spread on one of these images but
I asked you to forget is term
immediately glossy is the mixture of the
two so it is not like a mirror but it's
not like a completely diffused
so there is some view dependence in this
is material they are completely
independent mirrors are completely view
dependent so it's like a mixture of the
two it is possible that there are some
glossy materials in this scene can you
find them raise your hand if you see at
least one many of you okay
yes I want to cover the cupboard
excellent yes anything else
just shout at me anymore
yes run there's no food please you mean
this on the floor and like the cooking
the cooking food goes slow go slow
oh yeah yeah exactly exactly that's also
blocks it so there is many examples that
I think the question would be what is
math glossy in this scene the better
this would be a better question and the
table you are sitting here is also
positive it is a bit you dependent but
it's not only relatives but completely
diffuse and it also transfers the
caustics so it has some diffusivity okay
next question is it looks good but the
mathematician guy asks how accurate is
this we have these two images one of
these is generated by means of global
illumination solving this equation and
the other one is a photograph
do you know which is which raise your
hand if saw
okay one person - okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna spoil all the fun and title
solution okay
so look at this part so this is the
difference that you can see for instance
because this is an actual box that
that's the guys put together at Cornell
University and you cannot only see the
box in the photograph but what is next
to the box
whereas in Google illumination these
surroundings are not models just to
Konya box itself so we can remove that
yes this can be distinguished from a
photograph but if you get the actual
scene it is very and if everything is
perfectly implemented then this is so
close to physical reality that it is
literally in distinguish so this is
really amazing that we can do this
whenever you see out there in the world
we can model with this equation there
are exceptions because there are wave
effects such as diffraction and stuff
like that
but these are very rare I mean there are
butterflies who look the way they do
because of interference and then these
effects but 99% of what you see can be
modern with this equation and the rest
can be having fun or sophisticated
methods so back to this previous
question what is the dimensionality of
the rendering equation let's try to
think it through and we will see so
let's for just for now imagine that I
shoot array out from the camera and I
hit a diffuse object I need to sample
this hemisphere exhaustively this is not
how I will evaluate the algorithm but
technically this is what I need to do
all possible outcome directions have the
same probability so I need to shoot
these outgoing rays
any of them now I will hit more diffused
objects after the first bounce and I
have to exhaustively sample all of these
as well and if I take this utter a I
also have to do this and so on and so on
and so until how many bounces we have
concluded previously that we have to
take into consideration an infinite
number of processors so this is
definitely very difficult because the
incoming light that I am sampling the
hemisphere form is another rendering
equation so imagine that this Li you can
insert another one of these equations
but that equation will also contain this
image and this MMI and that's a matter
of entering equation so it's an
infinitely large sequence of integrals
therefore this is infinite dimensional
now I told you before that this is also
singular this is not such a bad thing
but this is because of the possibility
of specular brdf then the specular brdf
is some kind of the Delta distribution
and the other distributions are not
really functions so if in signal
processing you may have studied
dispassionate and the first thing that
they tell you about is that this is not
a function this can be defined in terms
of the limit so you can for instance
imagine like a Gaussian curve and you
you start pushing this Gaussian curve
from two sides therefore this is going
to be a larger and larger and thinner
and thinner spine and you do this until
you have an infinitely thin spike now if
you check it for the properties of the
function you will get something that has
nothing
the function that's that's a singularity
there is there's an infinitely quick
jump from zero to one in there and we
need to handle this somehow because we
can we can take into consideration
functions we can integrate functions so
let's just solve this trivially by
handling is a specular in the reflection
explicitly what does it mean this means
that if you have an incoming direction
you're not going to play with
probabilities you are just going to
graph like in a ray tracer you are just
going to grab the perfect reflection
direction as a lot of interaction no
probabilities not a beauty break we have
some scenario which is retracing because
of different things because the image
you create by means of ray tracing but
there is literally one ray of light
being reflected here many times so
awesome laser experiments with Lux
render we will try things out like this
a bit later during the course and
another example it's amazing what we can
do with these algorithms